joining us on the program from the Los
Angeles chargers and my fantasy football
team in that one league that I wanted to
win more than most Keenan Allen here on
the show how are you Keenan
I'm great how are you I'm doing fine
I'm doing fine where do I find you right
now Keenan where are you I'm at home you
are home yes okay did I see that you are
you having a baby or do you have a kid
what is your situation at home um the
baby's due in two days
oh come on yeah so we're we're about to
go on a walk yeah but walking can
sometimes cause it to happen right isn't
that for money yeah she's ready she's
ready she's ready to go so hold on a
second you are going on a Super Bowl run
where they ready to give birth wife
that's actually happening right now my
gosh I don't know what's tougher that or
Philip Rivers having eight children I
don't know what actually is difficult I
think so but you can have help there's
no real help when you've got your wife
who's ready I mean business she's ready
to go she wants to have this baby now
great way to go she needed to have him
before we leave please
oh boy or girl boy that's right I think
I saw your your reveal right did you
have it on on a practice field
yeah training camp well walk me through
that one I had to practice um she
brought the football we know this
happened I was going to do a rock copy
she brought the football I planted it it
was blue pretty exciting day my first
son I have two girls already so okay so
this is your third yes your third well
congratulations on that keen and
obviously and congratulations on on the
season that that's unfolding right now
what do you think of when you hear the
Chargers being called the most
fleet team in the NFL um I haven't
really looked at every team in NFL but
when I do look at I see a pretty
complete team the way the defense and
special teams played you know the end of
the season has been lights out and uh
one of the league's so when you put all
three of them together I think that's
what it comes down to is having a
complete team and um you know if we can
just keep staying consistent we keep
going what did Joe what does Anthony Lin
brought to the equation Keenan
leadership just installing that dog into
us um coming in and you know taking what
we want you know having that Raider
mentality coming innovated and you don't
taking it so that's what we've been
doing uh Dennis Rodman so success on the
rule and you know what is it about this
team that seems to perform better on the
road than at home is it because of the
makeshift digs that you're in right now
here in Los Angeles having moved from a
longtime fan base in San Diego is it
yeah I think I'm probably has a little
bit to play in it um you know we haven't
been in a comfortable home I was though
you know incluye so you know just being
comfortable being uncomfortable I was a
on the road you know we never had a I
don't know 80,000 so when we do get on
the road it is it's kind of beautiful ok
and now you're going on the road to
Foxborough where it's damn near
impossible to win in January Keenan and
it's expected and maybe have three or
five inches of snow
what do you say to the idea that a team
from Southern California having to go
across the country again play in the
early window again 10 a.m. I guess in
your mental clocks and in the snow that
you really don't have much for shot what
do you say that okay we got a bunch of
guys to let it play football
the guys who uh who grew up playing
football and um you know I think we
still have that same fun that we did
have a little cool so no I don't think
the weather's going to change anything I
don't think so no whether they want to
play it
yes at
so where are you from originally no
Carolina okay so you know the cold
weather then yeah yeah yeah I'm ready
for all that you are ready for all that
yeah Adam been there well I mean so yeah
I guess it's at a mindset cold is just a
mindset Kenan is that what you're saying
yeah when I'm gonna boss snap all that
cold I've got God's window how'd you
how'd you get to count my brother
transfer from Buffalo we wanted I wanted
to play with him once he was gonna
transfer um kind of just effort happenin
Peter Pez you know coach we were looking
at at the time right you know for both
of us at the for the best situation you
know you know that's how we have you
learn about it Keenan Allen here on the
Rich Eisen show are there are any times
where you have to calm sell it rivers
down Tina never over time to look down I
said guys when he that feels good but
he's talking John when he's going in
soon you know you locked in what sort of
junk does he talk about and I know you
can say it because it's safe for work
cuz you know every charger I've had on
here says he never curses it yeah no
keys you know locked in he knows he's
gonna put us in the right place and I've
only executed he's gonna look over to
people's coordinator he's know let him
know you know stop carving that I'm on
it you know I'm saying I stopped calling
that stuff though and if they you know
me and Mike tell someone I'm not sure if
he's uncle and that's a person know that
week isn't stuff like that so he'll go
up to somebody that you've just toasted
and and and and remind them about how
you are in fact toasting them that he
will do that Phillip will do that okay
so you want to you want to were you
surprised by the way Keenan that
linebackers were covering you in
Pittsburgh I was I mean I mean that's
kind of their scheme well teams don't
really come out of there being too much
hmm okay hey before I let you go Keenan
did you watch the national champion game
last night were you able to catch any of
that incredible what do you think of
that kid Trevor Lawrence
but I was more impressed with your
Sierra's obvious Justin Ross his number
right yeah that's referring to mention
Roth
what do you see him amazing 19 years old
he's a freshman playing on the biggest
boat I always thought number five was
special for Clemson yeah I know well I
mean everybody's talking about how
Lawrence could the quarterback could be
the number one overall pick in this
year's draft if he was allowed what are
you what do you think of the idea of a
19 year old quarterback playing in the
NFL and how just on it's just on its
face somebody that talented that you saw
last night at we're just delivering
those footballs do you think he would be
able to succeed no question no I don't
think you know the age has anything to
do with the way somebody can play ball
so my football you know I was a person
who always play younger and I was old
school so I mean you know I don't think
that would have anything to do with if
he can recover it is that he can do what
he needs to do with the quarterback
position and executed he can get tests
and Mike Williams I'm sure is gonna be
insufferable right to be wrong no quote
like that hey Keenan look
congratulations on on the birth so I'm
assuming is there a plan is this is this
boy coming today I mean this week before
you go - no matter what okay
that's why you're walking yeah no
question okay do you have a banana do
you have a name picked out already we
got a couple okay
Phillip is Phillip one of them Phillip
Allen no no no Kay Kay okay so just
trying to think of any of run off to
tell ya there's no K's on the team other
than you right okay all right take care
congratulations on your aunt's best to
your wife appreciate it that's Keenan
Allen they're going walking the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience